hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
there are some pretty awful products out
there today we all know that but in the
tech industry and especially the
high-tech stuff products are kind of
expected to come out once a year now a
product life cycle is around about one
year so the galaxy s 1 to the S 2 to the
S 3 to the S 4 it all takes one year in
between each of them the iPhone 4 to the
4s to the 5 it's all one year cycles in
fact some companies are even accused of
what's called planned obsolescence which
is where they basically intentionally
make products that are only valid until
the next product comes out and it kind
of gets you to buy the next version of
their product so iterations tend to last
about one year whether the company wants
you to or not but sometimes sometimes
there are products that don't even make
it through an entire life cycle products
that are so bad that they don't make it
that long I mean yeah some companies
will you know kind of be too proud to
discontinue a product even if it's not
selling that well they'll keep selling
it anyway
but sometimes the product is so bad that
a company has to discontinue it they're
forced to take it off the market or just
lose money because of its existence and
it's those miserable products that
inspire today's video so that any
further ado these are the fastest
discontinued products in text so apples
Power Mac g4 cube is actually a perfect
example of this it's a classic it lasted
for exactly 12 months between July 2000
and 2001 when it came out it was quote
the coolest computer ever in Steve Jobs
words in 2000 but a year later it turned
out quote most customers decided to buy
the Power Mac g4 instead and so the
Power Mac g4 cube was discontinued
Google's Nexus Q that sort of media
center thing was also killed off exactly
a year after its original announcement
the Google Play Movies app was the last
app to officially support that and an
app update came out for that exactly 365
days after the Nexus Q came out that
broke compatibility with it so on its
birthday the Nexus Q was unofficially
cut by Google but there are some
products that didn't even make it to the
one-year anniversary before getting the
axe in fact take a look at vigas mondo
portable handheld
gaming console it was first announced by
tiger telematics in 2005 and it was
supposed to be great for sort of
handheld racing gaming but it only sold
twenty five thousand units so it was
discontinued eleven months after it was
initially came out but it gets shorter
than that remember the juju tablet
probably not it was this Linux based
tablet that basically came out of
nowhere as a supposed I pad competitor
no one really heard of it but a burst
onto the scene so when it was finally
announced it turned out to be this
embarrassingly bad just terrible tablet
it was not only was it three quarters of
an inch thick and 2.2 pounds but it was
insanely slow just incredibly
unresponsive just a bad bad tablet and
retailed for more than the iPad that it
was supposed to be competing against so
just shot itself in the foot basically
there and so it was no surprise that
fusion garage pulled the plug on that
one in an embarrassingly short seven
months Nintendo had won to the Virtual
Boy console was supposed to be this sort
of 3d augmented reality wearable gaming
headset but the only problem with this
was this was 1995 so you can imagine 3d
augmented reality wearable gaming in
1985 it was not great it was a sort of
an awkward clunky form factor with an
awkwardly attached controller it only
displayed the color red when it played
these games and had a very limited
supply of 3d augmented reality wearable
games
honestly bottom line was this was
terrible a Nintendo pulled the plug on
this one in six months half a year
before the Nintendo just said no and
went on to making other better thing so
half a year can products really get
worse than only lasting for half a year
of course they get worse than that take
a look at Sony's evila
it was this sort of handheld but also
desktop portable Internet entertainment
console appliance thing it was way ahead
of its time no one really had any use
for it and no one bought one and the
fact that no one bought it meant that
Sony was losing money every time they
built one so that one was cut in a
ridiculously short three months luckily
Sony actually handled that one really
well though they refunded everyone who
was paying money for that if they
returned it and actually returned
everyone's
money who was paying the 2195 a month
internet plan to get internet on that
plan
so bottom line that was way ahead of its
time did so well at all but Sony pulled
it off in three months but there are
some products that did not even make it
three months into their cycle before
getting discontinued that's one quarter
of the one year cycle that we expect
tech to last and that's where we get
into our top five quickest discontinued
tech products for five is Google Wave
and this was actually one of two
failures from Google attempting to make
a sort of social network in 2010 the
other was Google Buzz but this one
lasted just 75 days that's actually
shorter than Kim Kardashian's wedding
believe it or not this was a product
that went public and immediately stopped
development seventy-five days later and
Google just open sourced it and said hey
you can have it this isn't really
working obviously Google Plus has done a
lot better than Google Wave it still
exists for one thing but yeah 75 days
for Google way that did not go well
speaking of Kim Kim Microsoft Kin
Microsoft skin was one of the strangest
legendary failures of a product it
lasted for a legendary 48 days and it
was funny because Microsoft actually put
millions of dollars of backstory into
this there was research and advertising
and marketing and hype and they all went
into making this piece of crap I
honestly don't know what they were
thinking that the entire backstory of
decane is honestly hilariously
depressing I'll include the whole wiki
about it down below the like button on
this video if you want to check it out
every line of that article is
cringe-worthy but hilarious and this kid
was just a massive failure of a product
so after 48 days they stopped selling it
and Verizon Wireless actually just
shoveled back all the ones that they
didn't sell to Microsoft which is
officially abandoning all hope Microsoft
then went on to shut down the online hub
that was necessary to keep these pieces
of crap running which made that a pretty
much useless product so they actually
started giving out free 3G smartphones
after the Kinze just went dead in the
water
this phone was a mess a very expensive
mess that lasted exactly 48 days for
Microsoft but number three was the HP
TouchPad which out does the Kin by just
one day and it only lasted 47 days it
was actually more famous for the fire
sale that went on after it was this
black or white webOS tablet that didn't
really sell well at all so HP decided
that they're just going to cut it and
sell them for $99 and not promise any
software updates and then people found a
way to put Android on it and there was a
massive flock to go buy these things and
make $99 Android tablets out of them
which was sad because they actually sold
more after they discontinued the product
than before that sucks so to beat that
we have a device that only lasted 30
days before essentially being
discontinued that's one month 1/12 of
the 1 year cycle that we expect tech to
last
that's the HTC first now ATT refuses to
acknowledge this but when you drop a
phone from $100 to $0.99 after only
15,000 sales that's basically
acknowledging its depth and to put that
under perspective the HTC ChaCha sold
better than that but that's only number
two and something had to be discontinued
faster than 30 days to beat that out for
the number one spot what is that the
Cisco flipped live this takes it to a
whole nother level remember those flip
cameras that everyone used to buy those
very inexpensive lightweight flip
cameras they were insanely popular
remember that cisco bought the flip
company for 590 million dollars and
started running it from there on out in
2009 and they continued to sell very
well so those 12 cameras are really
popular like we said among youtubers
vloggers do these very lightweight
inexpensive cameras that you can hold
out and record yourself it's not like
you're going to drop it it's very
lightweight so they sold really well so
cisco decided to hold a press conference
and announce an additional line up to
the flip cameras so they held a press
conference and decided that they would
have the flip live which would be a new
flip camera with Wi-Fi built in and some
bluetooth and some integration that
would talk to a computer and allow you
to stream video from the camera so they
line it up and announce that the product
would be available on April 13th that
year so the days in the weeks pass and
people are waiting for this interesting
new live streaming camera to go on sale
but unfortunately one day before it was
supposed to go on sale on April 12th
cisco decides to cut the entire flip
the entire company the whole thing they
fired 550 employees laid off everyone
and just chop that off chopped off the
whole arm of the Cisco branch that was
the flipped company so that sets a
record for never putting a product on
sale and having it discontinued after
negative one days
that's probably worthy of number one so
what do we learn here from these fastest
discontinued tech products well I can
say that I learned that it's safe that
you would want to know that a product is
bad before you release it that's kind of
a theme of all these products here
either way what was your favorite
quickly discontinued product it was
probably a failure and there's probably
no way to pick a favorite of the crappy
products that were all released but let
me know what was your favorite there are
plenty I didn't even mention like
Windows Vista and the Palm Treo or folio
I think it was called for example but
there are tons of other things that were
disconnected very quickly so feel free
to leave a thumbs up if you enjoyed this
video and leave a comment below of what
your favorite was either way thank you
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
in the next video